we have number three three six
three three six
thank you
um
it means everything in the world I mean
I can't even articulate how what an
honor this is and um my great
grandparents are German and I don't
speak a word of German so
um yeah it's
yeah a lot of faith and thank you to
Edward uh burger and Malta gunat for
you know installing this faith in me and
yeah I mean
I I can't I just can't I can't believe
it I can't I still can't believe it
all right next up we have number three
three six sorry three three six and
after 336 we'll have number one zero
three one
congratulations uh Mark Williams over
here on your left in the back from
in the back of the room waving my hand
ready from British cinematographer
congratulations on the win thank you
can you talk about the approach
unfortunately our species never runs out
of wars and they get increasingly well
documented visually from newsreels all
the way to cell phone capture now but
World War one exists in images mostly in
terms of narrative Recreation so what is
you use to Source your your visual
approach how did you work on it well the
the novel was everything to be perfectly
honest in the script and uh and
um you know we built it upon that but
also
um
just the way
warm makes you feel
okay
I don't know like it shouldn't feel it
should not feel beautiful it shouldn't
feel
um intelligible it should feel horrific
I mean this film is the closest thing to
a war film
the sorry sorry horror film sorry I do
apologize
um then that anything can be and yeah it
is it's a horrible it's really it's a
horror movie and it's uh yeah
yeah but but we you know
as far as photography is concerned I
think
um
yeah we we dug up some
World War One photographs but the one
thing that we actually didn't
or sorry we took from that was not the
uh
not the photochemical aspect of it but
the horror aspect of it and it's about
capturing that and yeah I that's what I
think that you know we tried to do sorry
next up we have number one zero three
and then we'll take our final question
from two two four
as you can imagine
uh congratulations James uh uh I
understand that this is a dream of yours
for a long time
um for any aspiring uh cinematographers
uh will be will be your advice to them
my advice to aspiring cinematography is
basically just keep keep pushing because
um
I I grew up as an electrician
uh in the film business and coiled cable
through mud and all sorts of
other horrible stuff and
um yeah if you believe in it and you
just want to tell stories then just keep
pushing and keep pushing and keep
pushing and there are some incredible
incredible storytellers out there and
yeah like
um I love to Mentor I was mentored by
two great cinematographers a guy called
Paul Wheeler
um and filmmaking
and who
I'm very privileged to have next to my
name and yeah
like they
um yeah seek mentorship seek
advice and but when the day is dark
don't give up just keep
pushing because that's the uh that's
yeah that's what that's what I can say
all right and final question from 224.
first of all congratulations and you
just won another Oscar
really yes
right so but my question is you have
been working on this movie for so long
how does did or does or did the war in
Ukraine change your perspective
um when we were shooting obviously the
war in Ukraine didn't exist but war in
general
um you know is very present and
um you know historical and it it's a uh
it's a lesson that we can
just sort of learn from really I like to
think but I
to be perfectly honest I I don't know
it's um we're we're obscene to
um keep
conflicts and yeah I do sorry I'm not
making a lot of sense but I'm just it's
uh yeah it's it's terrible I mean it's
absolutely terrible to be perfectly
honest and we should you know they
should be ashamed let's do a thank you
so much and congratulations on your two
wins
thank you thank you so much sorry for
being a bit inarticulate
[Applause]